[Music]
well we continue with team coverage the
school district also releasing
information about
sports for students sports director
chris matthews joins us in studio
with the plan for students waiting to
resume their athletics chris
well thank you kirsten yeah the power of
the people the governor's blessing has
prompted ccsd to initiate a plan to
return
high school sports earlier today a
three-hour meeting in north las vegas
with city leaders talking about the
importance
of sports helping facilitate the plan
city leaders and others talked about
sports being kind of the equity tool
that promotes
respect conflict resolution
responsibility and tolerance here
is the ccsd plan as it begins for the
kids here
for spring sports which by the way is
the busiest of all the prep seasons
practices will begin april 3rd with
competition beginning april 16th
for boys and girls track swimming diving
baseball softball
boys golf and boys volleyball for all
intramural
fall sports football fits in this
category there won't be a prep football
season
this spring in essence schools will have
spring football practices
allowing them to prepare for fall
football in august they'll have 20 days
of practice in april
wrap it up with a one-hour interest
squad game for the other intramural fall
sports
may 3rd through the 22nd those sports
will include boys and girls tennis cross
country girls volleyball
now these sports will be staggered to
avoid students choosing a single sport
there'll be 20 days of practice or intra
squad competition and finally
no spectators will be allowed at any of
those ccsd athletic events
schools will continue to follow all the
guidelines from the cdc and niaa
all coaches and adults associated with
the team will have to have a negative
test before
activities begin we all understand the
role of extracurricular activities
having the lives of those young adults
some adults at today's meeting in north
las vegas mention that sports
motivates those kids to actually excel
in the classroom and it gives the kids
who can't afford to be part of the
traveling clubs to play sports
an opportunity